sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and the
best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
plan show so today is going to be a
really exciting show we're trying to
understand what is going on with the
markets and what we can expect from
bitcoin throughout the rest of 2022 so i
have an amazing guest to delve into all
of this but before we dive in this
particular month is sponsored by um the
cryptocurrency exchange bitmex so a huge
shout out to bit max because without
them we won't be able to bring you such
valuable content as of may the 17th
they're actually launching a brand new
spot exchange to easily and instantly
buy and sell your crypto so to celebrate
they're giving away 1 million dollars in
crypto to sport traders over the next
few months and this is actually one of
the biggest giveaways in crypto right
now so if you are um eager to enter then
i'm gonna leave
some information with a link for you in
the description so it's gonna be really
exciting there's a huge range of
different assets that you can actually
trade on there so the information is all
in the description and a huge thank you
to bitmex because without them like i
said wouldn't be able to bring you such
exciting content so let's get into this
joining me today is lynn alden from lynn
order investment strategy to help us try
and make some sense of the markets lynn
how are you
good thanks for having me
yeah it's really great to have you i've
been following your content for a while
and you seem to be getting this spot on
you were early um with tara
predicting what was going to happen so
i'm really excited to get your
perspective on the markets right now but
before we get into all of this you have
a strong background in aviation so i'm
really interested to understand how you
went from the aviation industry into
finance where did that come into things
yeah it's a good question my background
is electrical engineering and
specifically i worked in the aviation
industry uh i started out as an engineer
and then i worked me up in into
engineering management and running the
finances of that facility um and going
back prior to that i had you know i had
a long-term kind of interest in finance
and investing
um as well as science and math and
technology and so i kind of pursued the
engineering field as my initial
profession while investing on the side
and then at some point i decided to
switch out of that and focus on
investing in you know public research
public writing full-time
and you do the traditional side of
things you know you talk about markets
like securities commodities um and then
you also get involved in crypto digital
assets so
this is really interesting because
they're obviously very different so do
you think that digital assets like
bitcoin are the future or in 10 to 15
years do you think that you're going to
continue to stay diversified with
traditional markets
well i mean i think it they basically
are a new
platform for things that already exist
so in many ways for example bitcoin is a
commodity right it's classified for most
tax purposes like a commodity you know
it doesn't pass the howie test so it's
not a security it's not an equity uh so
the best analogy we have for it is a
digital commodity and then you have
things like stable coins that are
digital fiat they're just digitally
native fiat it's a new medium for fiat
currencies and they have a variety of
other platforms that in many ways look
like
look like equities right for example
they have a network they have a platform
uh and then they invite people to use
their platform uh in various ways and
then people can judge what is the total
adjustable market of that platform what
does long-term outlook of that platform
look like uh and so you know i think
that that basically this is being
integrated into you know markets as they
currently are and we'll see what kind of
technologies come out of this
so in about 10 to 15 years you don't
think they're going to be considered
alternative markets
it's just going to be part and parcel of
how people trade essentially is that
what you're saying
well i think bitcoin will be here to
stay probably in 10 to 15 years i think
that has a long runway of growth ahead
of it before you know unless it runs
into some sort of tail risk so that's
number one i do think that stable coins
basically that money is going to flow
over blockchain rails more so i'm
bullish on the proliferation of stable
coins for example i think that's a
better medium than we'd be using in the
past um and then you know we'll find out
what the total just market is for
distributed compute basically you know
smart contracts federated networks uh
you know we'll see if they can be used
to bring down settlement times things
like that uh that's still a very highly
competitive industry and a lot of that's
been kind of based on i think artificial
incentives um and so when the dust
settles we'll see you know what is the
actual kind of underlying utility for
some of those technologies
yeah absolutely things are still playing
out um as they always say we are still
early so it's going to take some time to
sort of see what's going to
be there in the next next 10 to 15 years
but what we know is not necessarily
going to be there is something which you
predicted uh this week so i've never
seen anything quite like this um with
luna tanking to zero you predicted
exactly this i think about two weeks ago
on the first of may you said if the
lunar price declines ust would lose its
peg and the lfg um would have to sell as
bitcoin to stabilize ust so how did you
come to this analysis do you have to
have some kind of engineering finance
background like you to be able to have
this depth of knowledge how did you land
there
uh so that was mostly from analyzing it
as though i would have
analyzed an emerging market and they
were kind of using similar overall
economics and so for example if you look
at emerging market central bank uh you
know they issue liabilities which is
their emerging market currency and then
they have they they hold other assets
such as treasuries or gold that they can
use to defend that um and you know if
they start to run low on those reserves
you have to really get concerned about
that currency and so what essentially an
algorithmic stablecoin is it's kind of
like an emerging market central bank
that runs on autopilot
they're not really prone to stability
there they kind of always have these
inherent weaknesses
and
you know terror tried to shore up their
weaknesses by buying bitcoin in a
similar way that emerging market would
buy gold but my concern was that you
know in a in a risk-off environment
which is what we're in now uh you know
most of the crypto space tends to suffer
and when that happens to lunacoin
luna's like a total equity value
compared to their uh ust value uh that
can eventually erode the value of their
equity and result a death spiral which
is what we saw
so you predicted this perfectly well my
question is why were we able to get into
the situation where people have lost
their life savings i don't understand
how people weren't able to i don't know
speak loud enough about this those
running you know doc one why wasn't he
able to spot the weaknesses here how did
this happen
i think there are two things uh number
one
is that
it's hard you know it's so i kind of
outlined what would happen the question
was i didn't know when was going to
happen right so i don't know if it's
going to happen in may i don't know if
it's going to happen in june i didn't
know if they'd be able to salvage this
get more capital injection ahead of time
and push it back another year right so
it's hard to say when it's going to fail
so that's number one number two
is you know i think a lot of people in
the space they have a low incentive to
be critical and a high incentive to kind
of promote things uh and especially with
an algorithmic stablecoin it's really
based on confidence
uh and so it's always confidence
confidence confidence uh and i just
think not a lot not enough people were
critical now there were plenty of people
besides me uh and even some of those
helped inform uh the research i did
right i didn't just come up without a no
write i researched different things that
people were saying i did my own analysis
um and so there were plenty of people
out there i i just think that you know
too few people listened to them too many
people were wrapped up in the gains they
were having
yeah a lot of hopium as they say um they
sold i think it was confirmed today or
yesterday don't remember they they sold
around 80 000 bitcoin
what's the problem with using bit
bitcoin as collateral for other
blockchain networks because i know a lot
of people think that that's sort of some
of the reasons why the market's tanking
although bitcoin seems to be stabilizing
at around 30 000 what what are the
issues with using bitcoin's collateral
for other networks
so i think it's it's not necessarily
using bitcoin as collateral that's the
problem i mean it you know in some ways
it's ideal collateral it's still because
it's a young asset it's still volatile
though so it's less it's less uh you
know it's more volatile than treasuries
or gold or something like that so you
have to put up with volatile collateral
which is not ideal uh but i think the
bigger issue is that just by adding
bitcoin to something
doesn't fix that thing if that thing is
inherently unstable it doesn't matter if
you have bitcoin reserves because your
thing is unstable right and so you know
maybe if they had more they could have
you know they could have prolonged it
they could have had it this whole death
spiral will be a lot slower than it was
it would have been less spectacular um
but basically you can't fix a broken
system by adding bitcoin to it um and so
you know if a company wants to add
bitcoin to their reserves as a
percentage of their long-term holdings i
think that can make sense um but if you
are inherently an unstable protocol uh
bitcoin doesn't fix that
i'm interested given the amount of
research and your understanding um on
this digital asset space
what would you say you're most bullish
on which would withstand the test of
time then
so i the two areas that i'm bullish on
in the crypto space are bitcoin and
stable coins um
and you know really with bitcoin what
we're seeing is the test of this new
asset we're seeing how hard it is we're
seeing if we can stand community
disagreements softworks you know all the
different challenges there so far it's
been able to withstand that
and so i think that's a long term then
it's going to withstand the test of time
uh most likely and then the other one
would be
that there is a strong global demand for
money for low volatility money which is
stable coins basically uh and the way
fiat currency works is that they they
try to control volatility by devaluing
gradually over time right so a dollar
loses value year after year year but in
most circumstances it doesn't
explosively lose value over say a
two-month period
and there's you know the people around
the world where you know they're living
in double-digit inflation
uh they have restrictive monetary
regimes and you know for example in
argentina or lebanon if you had dollars
in the bank let's say you made the
decision you don't want to hold the
local currency you want to hold dollars
uh they just took the dollars they can
just take them and convert them to local
currency
and then you get devalued anyway and so
ironically for them for people you know
they'd rather trust you know a foreign
custodian
uh they could hold dollars to them on
the blockchain and take any sort of
risks that might come with you know the
the quality of their collateral things
like that
versus storing dollars in their own
banking system uh and so i think the
combination of bitcoin long-term and
stable coins kind of you know
intermediate term uh i think both those
things are real use cases above and
beyond speculation uh that i think are
going to persist for quite a while in
this
industry people keep looking at bitcoin
as this like you said you know something
which is it's new but it's sort of
withstanding the test of time it's a
hedge against whatever's happening um
but inflation is just hit a 40-year high
um the fed is
you know increasing interest rates to
try to tackle this so do you think that
bitcoin is going to be able to
withstand this supposed recession which
is coming
so i think it will withstand that but
there is significant price risk over the
next 12 months
uh and if you look back historically
you know we can even put the question of
recession aside and just look at
economic acceleration or deceleration
because not all decelerations result in
outright recession
and so over the past decade for example
you can measure it in the purchasing
managers index which is a basically
measure of economic activity and it
looks kind of like a sine wave that goes
up and down every three years
and some of those downturns result in
recessions and other ones result in say
near recessions they almost cause
recession but there's some sort of
monetary policy pivot or fiscal stimulus
that kind of reflates it from there uh
and so historically bitcoin has
generally done very good in rising pmi
environments so economic acceleration
liquidity is flowing most most risk
assets do well and something with a lot
of volatility like bitcoin generally
does even better
then of course many of the altcoins you
know they skyrocket and then when you
have the declining pmi environment
uh all coins get killed bitcoin suffers
uh stocks in general especially riskier
ones uh overvalued ones tend to suffer
whereas things like cash defensive value
stocks gold those sort of assets
generally hold up better and right now
we're kind of firmly in the middle of a
declining pmi environment
uh now that doesn't mean that bitcoin
can't you know like in the in the prior
declining pmi environment it managed to
bottom before pmi bottom it doesn't just
follow this this perfectly uh so i think
we've already seen quite a lot of the
washout whether or not we get a lower
low i still think is anyone's guess what
makes this one so challenging is that
because inflation is high the fed is is
trying their best to tighten monetary
policy into a weakening environment
they're appropriately trying to reduce
demand
and basically cause a near recession
and i i think that's not going to go
well for them i think they're going to
have to reverse at some point but until
you get that reversal
i think we are in rather risky
territories or especially if i was
trading any sort of leverage i'd be
super careful uh and then even unlevered
people have to make sure that they have
the right amount of exposure
for whatever volatility they can afford
so i would never recommend someone put
100 of the portfolio in bitcoin
and things like that i just think you
know whatever allocation you want to it
based on your education on the asset
your conviction uh what you think is
going to be worth in five 10 years you
can have that allocation and i think you
have to be willing to withstand a lot of
price turbulence over the next 12 months
or at least until we see some sort of
reversal from these current conditions
which is economic deceleration combined
with monetary tightening which is you
know pretty much anything other than
cash and defensive value things
are are going to have rough time there
they say that bitcoin is this
uncorrelated asset i mean it's obviously
not given everything you've just said
but do you think we'll get to a point
where it's going to be uncorrelated and
we're not going to have to deal with
everything that you mentioned
so historically it's been moderately
uncorrelated compared to stocks um it's
still generally risk on liquidity play
uh and in the past few years the
correlation went up quite a bit i think
there's a couple reasons for that one is
that the macro situation was a bigger
common variable between assets so we had
the biggest ever uh injection of
liquidity combined with the biggest ever
removal of liquidity and so vast
majority of assets went up and down
together and only kind of specific
things like energy start kind of
breaking out of that correlation uh and
so
the other factor would be that bitcoin
got big enough that it's now like an
institutional asset and so you have
hedge funds trading it you have a lot of
professional money trading it and so the
venn diagram of who owns bitcoin versus
who owns the nasdaq came together uh
quite a bit
there's still there's environments where
i think that could decouple one would be
if you see a reversal of fed tightening
so you have more liquid in the market
but say you still have that combined
with
uh inflationary pressures on company
margins that could be an environment
where stocks you know they might not do
that well whereas you know commodities
including gold and bitcoin could do
pretty well because they're benefiting
from liquidity without having to worry
about margin pressure they don't have
employees they don't have margins
they're they're just you know these
scarce assets uh so that could certainly
result in a decoupling another one would
be that you know even though the the two
types of holders have kind of come
together they're still not completely
the same it's not the same people all on
bitcoin and nasdaq
and so for example a lot of people are
dollar cost averaging in a bitcoin and
they're not buying the nasdaq and
eventually you can dry up all the
liquidity basically exhaust all the
sellers and then get a reversal i think
that's you're most likely to see that
when you have more liquid in the market
and when you have a rising pmi
environment
so just going back a sec to
this looming recession which is
supposedly coming
what
what does this mean for the the everyday
person
people are always looking for
the best way to hedge themselves against
this recession against inflation and
we've kind of been looking at bitcoin as
as sort of this answer don't worry about
the stock market just pick bitcoin don't
worry about property just pick bitcoin
so
where does the average person go from
here when they know that this recession
is coming
so
to take a step back i think we can
describe it we're in an economic
decelerating environment that might or
may not go into a full recession i i
think on the current track we are likely
headed towards one but i would i would
just you know caution against saying you
know a recession is sure i think what we
can say for sure in the data currently
is that we're in a decelerating economic
environment so that's that's number one
number two you know talk about the
average person that can vary
tremendously based on what country
you're in right i mean someone in turkey
has a different currency situation to
deal with than someone in canada for
example right and so
right now the dollar is at the heart of
the global fentanyl system so when the
fed's tightening you know basically the
reason why
when
the economy goes down and the fed
tightens the reason why dollars you know
pretty much go up compared to almost
everything else is because that's the
that's the unit that debt is denominated
in uh and you're basically tightening
everyone's debts relative to their
assets uh and so everything that's
basically denominated in dollars uh you
know struggles uh and so in that type of
environment if you were
in the united states or other developed
countries holding a larger normal cash
position can help you get through that
kind of turbulence and then you can
deploy it when you see some sort of
pivot you can get into whatever risk
assets you prefer
whereas if you are if you're in a
periphery market if you're in a market
that's suffering currency problems
whether it's argentina or turkey and
things like that you know those hard
assets are still
working better for you than owning your
local currency uh it doesn't mean every
single week or every single month but if
you look at a long-term chart of say
bitcoin priced in turkish lira
uh you know there's no there's no doubt
that it's a good inflation hedge uh same
thing for for gold or same thing if you
hold dollars stable coins things like
that so i think the way that people can
interact with this depends on where they
are in the world what their liabilities
are denominated in and and what they're
kind of experiencing in their local
markets um so i think that basically the
general trend
is that when you have this kind of risk
off
uh you know fed tightening economic
decelerating environment you generally
want to be more defensive and that can
mean different things for different
people in the world and then we have
that kind of rising pmi fed loosening
type of environment that's when you can
consider taking on more risk
and you know another way to phrase this
is that right now we have a lot of
scarcity in things that we want
especially energy energy is scarce and
then because that's the master resource
that affects food scarcity uh and all
these other things
and the fed can't print more oil they
can print more ships and ports they
can't print more wheat all they can try
to do is try to reduce the demand for
those things that that's that's the way
that they can try to deal with inflation
but reducing demand is basically
synonymous with a recession that's what
a that's what a recession is basically
reduction economic activity uh and so in
their minds they're trying to do a just
a small one right you know just trying
to take the edge off demand without
causing an outright recession
historically the odds of doing that are
very low right so if you
it's like you know it's like being a
little bit pregnant right the fed has a
bad track record of being a little bit
pregnant either they they feel recession
or they don't uh and at least more often
than not and so they're kind of on the
track now they're trying to curtail
demand and so
that you know that challenges people in
different ways inflation's a challenge
for people and then also when the fed is
purposely trying to reduce demand that's
also challenging for people so i think
right now it's kind of you want to
buckle down you want to make sure you
have access to the supplies you need and
you want to be defensive whatever that
means for your personal situation
why do you think we've gotten into this
sort of mess i mean i know we've seen
endless amounts of money printing over
the last two years
we have you know anonymous
accounts on twitter been tweeting don't
print money that's bad like how can
these you know anonymous accounts on
twitter with probably no financial
background say don't print money that's
bad and then the fed prints money and we
end up in this situation so
is this done on purpose is this out of
um
lack of intelligence i don't know
why we in such dire straits
i i think the seeds of this go back
decades i think that's the hard part
it's kind of like this big shift there's
no there's no single person responsible
for it it's the accumulation
of moderately bad decisions over decades
until it becomes a severely bad
situation uh and so basically every time
we have a downturn
right so decades ago if you have a
downturn
uh you know you could just let it play
out let the bad leverage go away let it
play out uh they chose not to do that
they chose to inflate the next bubble um
and basically you know get convinced
people to take out even more debt
and the problem is you eventually blow
such a big bubble that you can never
retract it you know basically that
basically would crash the even the
government bond market if it were to
contract and so they're pretty much the
only way out there is to inflate it away
they have to hold interest below the
inflation rate and you you can't kind of
deleverage enough debt nominally so you
have to basically increase the
denominator which is currency units
until you quote unquote fix the problem
and of course that's a very
uncomfortable situation for most market
participants and i think that's the
stage of the cycle we're in although
there's there can be kind of
you know intermediate term pushbacks
right so right now where they're kind of
they don't want to admit that's what
they're doing so okay we're going to
tighten we're going to tighten policy
and i think what's going to happen is
the economy is going to weaken enough
that they're going to have to stop
tightening
and then you know inflation is still
high and they have to pivot and then
they're kind of out of excuses so i
think that this the problem now is the
accumulation of moderately bad decisions
and then you have other things layering
on top of that like the commodity cycle
right there's there's there's periods
where you know commodity prices are high
everybody comes in and you know they
drill new wells they find new copper
deposits they they put all that capex in
until they have too much supply and then
you get a you know decade long bad
prices no no new capital wants to come
in
until you burn off all that excess
supply uh and that's kind of what we're
now we we just had a uh you know more
than a 10-year period of reducing
commodity prices outright deflationary
commodity prices in most cases uh and
that era i think is behind us i think
we've already used up a lot of the
excess supply that we've had uh and now
we're kind of entering this another
period of scarcity where until we get a
lot of new commodity and infrastructure
supply online we're gonna have problems
uh in terms of having disinflationary
growth so we're either going to have
economic contract contractions or we're
going to have very inflationary types of
growth uh because it's the combination
of the currency being a problem and
under investment in hard assets and you
mentioned that
depending on which country you're in
your situation is is is unique to you
that you know you have different
liabilities um which is interesting
because today it was announced that um i
think it was 44 heads of states are
heading to el salvador to discuss
bitcoin um el salvador seems to be
clearly very much underwater with that
bitcoin investment so i want to get your
take on
how smart you think that their move is
so i think their decision to include
bitcoin as legal tender smart i think
they've gotten a lot of tourism and
investment out of it
um the problem is that those types of
decisions don't come freely right and so
the biggest risk for them is that
foreign creditors don't want to buy
their bonds anymore uh and so their
costs of financing are very very high
um and so i think that's the biggest
issue challenging them right that
basically the current kind of system is
built to try to have it so the countries
can't leave the system right and so if
you try to leave the system you know you
better be prepared to deal with the
consequences and so i think that's what
they're going through now um so you know
bitcoin can't just instantly fix a lot
of the issues that el salvador has
related to crime related to all you know
all the challenges that historically
face the country um and so when you
combine that with you know the imf and
other entities kind of pushing back on
you
you know that's a challenge and so in
any sort of declining pmi environment
when the fed's tightening basically what
they're doing is they're breaking all
the countries that have that have kind
of done their own thing and we'll see
which ones can get through it i i still
open questions about how
successful el salvador is going to be in
navigating this um and i think that
remains to be seen i think there's very
little downside
you know say outside of what the foreign
creditors are going to do there's very
little downside in saying
you know we accept this other currency
as for as legal tenure in addition to
the one we already were right so they've
not made dollars non-legal tender they
still are
and if anything the data shows i mean
you know the vast majority of economic
activity is still in dollars
um and so you know i don't think that
the direct implications of using bitcoin
have been a problem for the country i
think it's the international creditor
reaction to that decision
why do you think they've had such a bad
reaction
well partially because they like the
status quo so if a country tries to
leave that status quo
uh that's you know that's not good in
their eyes they want to punish them
another thing i think is that large like
managers of large pools of capital are
you know they consider this risky it's
outside of the bounds of things that
they're familiar with and they say you
know what i just don't want to own el
salvador bonds that's an easy you know
if i have a portfolio of bonds from 50
developing countries and this one did
something that i understand and it's
it's one percent of my portfolio it's
easy for me to be you know what it's i'm
just going to take that money out and
i'm going to put it into another country
that i understand and so i think the
combination
of just a lot of creditors that just
said i don't really want to have
exposure and so that comes down we'll
see if they can get alternative
financing and we'll see to what extent
that this can pay off in the long term
even though the actual decision of
having bitcoin legal tender has had
neutral to positive uh implications as
far as at least as far as i can see
yeah no i don't agree with you i mean i
i haven't yet been to el salvador but
i'm excited to go um for tourism reasons
um so yeah i imagine it's had a huge um
it's brought a huge amount of new new
people in which is really exciting
um but okay so back to the markets just
for a second so given billions of
dollars has been wiped off the market
very quickly um where do you think we
are right now rao power and willy woo
for example talk about this four year
cycle being over so it's not really
driven by the bitcoin harvey anymore so
i'd be really interested to know your
thoughts on that um and sort of where
you see us going like you know from
after the next 12 months to maybe 18 to
2 years 18 months or two years
i think it's investors want to focus on
one cycle it would be the u.s purchasing
manager's index cycle so that that pmi
cycle that already referenced and that's
roughly a three year cycle there's no
rule that says it has to be three years
it just historically has been about
three years uh that's kind of the cycle
of investment decisions um and things
like that and so i think if you follow
the pmi cycle over time
uh that can give you a general idea of
what's going to happen with risk on
versus risk off assets
now that that applies
as measured in dollars right so if
you're in a country that's having a
spiraling inflation problem
uh you could probably ignore that and
just focus on you want to own hard
assets you don't own your local currency
in large amounts um so you know mostly
they're referring to investors that
would denominate their you know their
unit of exchange in dollars um so i
would i would say that we're still in
this kind of risk off environment it
doesn't mean we're necessarily going to
get lower lows i have no idea okay but
it generally means that excess risk
taking is probably not where a lot of
capital is going to flow to
uh and so you want to look for either a
rising pmi environment or some sort of
federal reserve monetary policy pivot
and in that kind of rising liquidity
cycle is where i think bitcoin would
have its next bull run which i i think
at the current time you point out to
2023
uh sometime in that time frame but again
these cycles there's no hard focus on
them and bitcoin is not bottom and top
you know precisely with the cycle even
though it is closely aligned
historically with those cycles
the interesting thing is every metric um
on the bitcoin network is looking pretty
healthy right now the hash rate is at an
all-time high um bitcoin is coming off
of exchanges at record highs i think i
read today that um the amount of uh
wallets holding um one whole bitcoin has
just hit record highs user adoption is
going up quickly so in your opinion
other than you know this
inflation and everything that we've
spoken about
what do you think is holding the price
down
uh so certainly one of the factors was
what happened with tara and that was one
of the concerns i wrote about ahead of
time which is that if they have to force
sell tens of thousands of bitcoins into
the market um you know that's in an
already weak market that's not great for
price and so we saw looking at exchange
data for example is that you know the
record you know coins were coming off
exchanges then you had this big
injection of coins back onto exchanges
most likely associated uh with the the
tara luna you know uh defense uh and
then since then it's come off a little
bit you know there's some dip buyers
that probably bought in and bought some
cheap sats uh but it's still higher than
it was before
uh the luna event um and so i think that
they basically there's tens of thousands
of coins that have to find a new home so
there's kind of you know and then
there's people that are shocked by the
price they have we can selling strong
hands buying the dip and i think you
have to have that rotation
until you basically exhaust the sellers
um and the buyers are still happy
and so that's kind of what happens in
this in this risk off type of
environment another thing is that you
know now all the coins are moving on on
chain right a lot of it's just happening
within exchange ledgers it's also
happening in futures markets uh and so
basically there's very few large fast
money pools of capital that are like you
know what
i want to buy bitcoin right now right
that's not that's not what we're seeing
they're basically i want to be risk off
right now until i have better clarity on
what's going to happen with liquidity
what's going to happen with the economy
uh and so because it's that risk-off
environment the marginal buyer is not
really showing up there's not a lot of
outside capital flowing into space and
so you have a difference between what
say the
you know the hodlers are doing right so
they're they're showing very strong
adoption uh we've seen a number of
people that say we're in the luna system
and then they say you know what i'm a
bitcoin maxi now you know so yeah you
have some rotation there but then you
also just have large pools of capital
that are like you know i'm gonna i'm
gonna let the dust settle and see what's
happening with macro before i put in new
capital so basically obviously overall
demand is is relatively weak at the
current time even though there's pockets
of obviously very um you know strong
demand
yeah you make a funny point the best way
to make a bitcoin maxi is to have weeks
like this i think there's a lot of
bitcoin maxies that have been converted
um but what do you think about bitcoin
versus bitcoin derivatives for example
everyone is pushing for the spot etf
which is good for mass adoption but is
it better to hold the actual bitcoin um
or bitcoin derivatives that can
obviously be manipulated
so there are different pools of capital
that have different requirements so i
think if you're in a position where you
can i think it's better to own the
underlying bitcoin you know that's kind
of the
part of the reason the asset is
desirable is because you can hold it
without counterparty risk right you can
hold it you can hold your own wallet you
can have multi-signature solutions uh so
i think that's ideal when possible but
there's some types of monies that is
401k money uh you have it with an
advisor you have it in fidelity whatever
the case may be you have in your
brokerage and maybe you want bitcoin
exposure there uh and you don't want it
maybe you don't want to have to worry
about maybe maybe you're fine with
counterparty risk you'd rather trust
fidelity than yourself right and i think
there are plenty of people that maybe
want to be in that position or they want
to split the difference they want to say
look i have my own stack but i also want
to have additional exposure that maybe
is in my brokerage account and so i
think that there's different types of
products for different pools of capital
um there's also you know say a pension
or other you know kind of large entity
like that insurance company you know
their charter might you know restrict
them to buying securities right that
they they might not put all in the
underlying property and so they want a
rapper around it someone to manage it on
their behalf
and it could be grayscale could be you
know one of these other types of
entities
and so i think basically we have to be
aware that there are different pools of
capital that have different
goals with what they're trying to do
with it and different appreciation of
counterparty risks or even preferring
having a counterparty and so i think
you're going to see that show up you
know across the board i think the more
products that are available the better i
think there should be a bitcoin etf
because a lot of people have had to buy
interior products
due to a lack of a bitcoin etf and so
ironically
it's not investor protection it's if
anything it is it's funneling investors
into weaker types of investments you
know they're either buying something
that is not necessarily keeping up with
the price of bitcoin it might be futures
based it might have it's it might not
trade with net asset value it might be
an entity that takes on leverage
basically people have been forced into
those things if they want bitcoin in
their normal brokerage account so i
think
over time you know the more products
available the more can be normalized uh
in terms of having a small slice in your
401k or small slice in your insurance
holdings things like that
when do you think we'll see a small etf
you know so i don't have regulatory
clarity on that uh i think
i i would say probably the next couple
years we already have bitcoin etfs the
question is when we have one in the
united states right and so yes yeah yeah
kind of i think shame the united states
has been behind on this compared to
other countries
um so i you know i would not be shocked
if weeks from now
you know we have a bitcoin etf like we
have a announcement of a bitcoin etf but
i also wouldn't be shocked if we're
sitting here a year and a half from now
and we still don't have one i think
there's basically a small number of
people that have to decide
that there can be one now and so
whatever would convince those people
it seems to be that the
because we see so much casino-like
behavior on the exchanges that they that
that seems to be a factor in terms of
not having a bitcoin etf which i don't
think that necessarily makes sense but
it might be a piece of leverage that
regulators have over the exchanges so i
you know i don't really have a strong
conviction on when we'll have a bitcoin
etf but then i think in the long run i
think we'll have one
what's your take on regulation um janet
yellen obviously was saying how the
market needs to be regulated better
after um everything that happened with
terror um we obviously don't the us
obviously doesn't have the sport etf yet
so it's really the us is very much
behind
um so how do you think regulation is
going to play out for the u.s do you
think that it's going to actually be
able to remain at the forefront of
innovation when it comes to the digital
asset space
so i think i think the problem is that
they want to in their view protect
consumers without suppressing innovation
and one of the challenges there is that
we right now because the technologies
progressed faster than regulators know
what to do with we kind of have two
markets right so normally if you if you
have a something that passes the howie
test basically your security then
there's various restrictions you have if
you want to sell that to the public
you have to have certain disclosures and
things like that um whereas in the
digital asset space someone can make
something that for all accounts is a
security and then they can just sell to
people uh and so you know someone from
say a very libertarian background says
that's fine but the problem there is and
you have two different types of markets
so you know some people might say
everything should be you should sell
whatever you want to the consumer other
people might say no we need restrictions
but few people would argue that there
should be basically like inconsistent
regulations where if you're if you're
you know in this category you can't sell
the public but if you're in this other
category you can sell the public and so
i think over time we're going to see
more unification between securities laws
and traditional assets and securities
laws and digital assets i think
basically some more of those tests will
be applied to
some of those projects and so for
example it's already the case that most
of them they can't you know raise
capital from you know the the broad uh
you know american public right now we
could see more restrictions on what
exchanges can sell to the public right i
mean a lot of exchanges were funneling
investors into you know mean coins right
at the top of their their part of the
cycle you know it's basically whatever's
got momentum they advertise that they
get a lot of people in and those people
get wrecked um and then you know we see
just a lot of exchanges we're selling
luna and then later said that oh we knew
that project was doing fulfilled well
why did you sell it to the public then
or why did you know so i think i think
that there's going to be
a little bit more tightening around
what exchanges
yeah can make it easy for the public to
access
and i don't think that really affects
bitcoin per se but i think that affects
some of the worst uh areas of the
altcoin space
and then there's other
i think there's more problematic
concerns like making it harder to
custody your own funds
um so i i would certainly be against
those types of regulations i think
people should have the right to
self-custody their own funds but i think
that's something we're seeing pop up in
the european union uh you see it pop up
from some lawmakers we'll see what can
actually get made into law
well that's interesting because i i saw
that within the eu they were talking
about um i think it was you have to
screenshot your wallet address or
something like that if you're using a
non-custodial wallet before you send it
i don't understand how that could be
implemented so how on earth could you
implement
self like i don't know regulation around
self custody i can't i can't understand
that
i think it's gonna be a very big
challenge and that's actually even that
goes back to what nakamoto's innovation
was so prior to bitcoin if you want to
send money long distances you needed to
go through a central intermediary a bank
basically um and
so if you wanted to if you wanted to do
capital controls or sanctions or
restrict where money can flow the
government only had to focus on
financial institutions which is really
easy to do
uh what this did is it opened up
peer-to-peer transactions across the
world and so if you want to enforce
those types of laws you now have to
enforce it on the consumer layer which
is orders of magnitude harder to do
because you say in america you're
focusing on 330 million people rather
than a few thousand banks right and so i
think that that is in the long run
rather untenable um now
one of the ways you can do it is
draconian restrictions where you say
okay we can't really enforce it too much
but if we catch you
uh the penalties are severe and that's
actually what they did when they banned
gold i mean in the united states you
couldn't own gold it was illegal to own
gold for like four decades from the
1930s uh up to the beginning of 1970s
and the penalty was up to 10 years in
prison now the number of people that
actually were charged with any of that
was low they didn't go door to door and
get everyone's gold it was really just
you know something that they could not
enforce then instead they enforced
through draconian penalties so we'll see
if that's the route that they try to
take but essentially the whole point of
this entire field the whole innovation
here the the foundation for what makes
this space interesting uh especially
bitcoin and stable coins is that they
basically unlocked global peer-to-peer
payments
and that's kind of a pandora's box that
i think
you know i think different entities
around the world are going to struggle
with and i think it's obviously a bigger
problem for more authoritarian types of
places and it's less of a problem for
places where you actually want to live
and they actually have a functioning you
know economy
so that brings you into my last topic um
cbdc's because i know that you're like
you said you're bullish on stable coins
um but how do you think cbdc's will be
adopted versus stable coins do you think
we'll have both or do you think or do
you think one could essentially replace
the other in terms of orderless payments
no volatility and so on
i think that depends on the jurisdiction
right and so a country like china
pursued the cbdc route over the
stablecoin route one is that they got a
big head start i mean they started
studying that in like 2014 uh and after
years of research and development they
they've introduced uh you know their
version of the cbdc they also have very
few kind of checks and balances on their
government uh they're obviously uh prone
to surveillance and control
so that's kind of right up their alley
whereas if you look at the united states
uh you know our officials generally did
not research this very early on um and
and so they're
now they're kind of in catch-up mode and
you know in these types of environments
generally public private partnerships
tend to be what's used right so the
federal government will often use
contractors for example instead of
making all of our own military equipment
we'll have lockheed martin make it we'll
have boeing make it uh and so i think in
in the united states and some of these
other similar types of countries you're
more likely to see stable coins
regulated stable coins be used as
essentially that mechanism uh and so
that regulator is still sort of that out
so i i don't have super high conviction
on what what this is going to look like
but i do think that over time
um probably some degree of outside
partnerships would be used so for
example the united states can pardon a
circle and say okay that this this is a
quote-unquote bank quality stable coin
you can use it for these purposes
whereas this other one is not right and
so i think that's kind of the route that
we're probably going to see
in in parts of the western world
lynn it's been so fascinating hearing a
perspective on all of this given the
state of the world and the market right
now so i really appreciate you coming on
um do you have any last thoughts um
about you know what's going on right now
people who might be potentially
concerned because they're very much
underwater with their investments and
what are your last thoughts
i think this the final thought is to
make sure you understand what you own
make sure you have an assessment of a
long-term utility of what it is that you
own
uh and and stick to things you
understand because i think this is still
you know whether or not we've seen the
bottom you know this is obviously that
this was a uh a big crashing moment
associated with the terror collapse uh
so you know whether or not was the
bottom or not i think things that don't
have long-term utility still have more
to lose
and then even things that are high
quality can be temporarily dragged down
by deleveraging in associated assets and
so i think it's a it's a risk-off
environment
and you want to be careful with your
leverage and with your exposures and to
make sure that you own you own the
things that you think have a good five
to ten year time horizon ahead of them
in terms of where this industry is going
where can people follow your work
uh so i'm at lynnlawton.com and i'm on
twitter at lenon contact
guys please go follow lin um just
amazing value that predicted everything
that was going to happen and with the
tara luna situation so that was really
fascinating lynn thank you so much for
coming on it's been such a pleasure
learning from you
thanks for having me
guys thanks so much for tuning in don't
forget to hit the subscribe button and
we'll see you all next week malaya high
or pancho